chicks have this type of confidence you
know it happens to guys that like come
on my show and they'll be like oh she
was cute and I was like she's like 50
pounds overweight what do you mean you
know I think it has a lot to do with it
as well and this you might not agree
with me on this but I feel like lockdown
had a lot to do with men and how we move
in this day and age because a lot of men
during lockdown wasn't able to do what
they was doing before I feel like women
took more control after that in the
sense of now I feel like it's harder for
guys to get girls because of I feel that
social media boosted at that point
whereas before it was there but it
wasn't so important whereas now you have
to be a certain level of caliber in
order to get recognized I think what it
is is you still have eighty percent of
the girls going for the top 10 of guys
it's always been like that but it's been
more visible now thanks to stuff like
social media right so that's why and
that's what I said earlier about the
reality thing because they live in their
own reality to them every guy is six
foot three every guy earns this amount
of money every guy dialogue studies Etc
et cetera and that filters down to other
things because then they also think
those kind of guys usually have a lot of
options therefore they might mess about
a little bit they might cheat whatever
so now they think oh guys cheat well not
really you're ignoring 80 of the guys
because you're only dealing with the top
20. so they have a very skewed view of
what guys are there's guys like we said
earlier ugly guys
ugly guys won't matter
like if they're if they substance like
supplement it with other things money
look status etc etc etc right so if but
there's a big big proportion of guys who
aren't doing that and those kind of guys
are completely invisible to girls but
you know do you know what that's what
I'm saying here I think a man's value is
not determined by how attractive he is I
agree yeah so when when a woman puts all
the emphasis on a man's Beauty
that's a masculine woman yeah I think
and I think a lot of the things where
you said about the person being like 50
pounds overweight I think a lot of the
time females forget about intention so
like just because the man might say yeah
cute
he might just be trying to do that oh
he branded like a girl overweight below
above average but the thing is though in
in the in that his real mind though he
might be saying to you like yeah if he's
a seventh but in his real mind he's
thinking of four but he's looking but
but he wants to do that and then what
happens when we're having all of these
conversations we're distorted the
females break left next thing you know
it's just a one big blurred line and I
think that when you mention obviously
going for different looks and because I
think you said something about three for
three four four five or five because
that girl that makes maybe a four
got the man for an that was a man
it's all Matt you see you see when guys
are rating girls seven eight and nines
that's just in their world in the real
world that rating drops by like three
years you guys are in London so it's
like a little bit they're not that cute
here um
a guy will actually over inflate the
rating for a girl depending on his
current
um mindset so if he's been starving for
a while so he's horny a guy who's horny
is obviously going to actually think of
the guy as more attractive like I've
I've I'm sure a lot of guys have
experienced it before you're very in the
mood you haven't had it for like a
couple of days or a week or something
and then you start seeing girls who you
wouldn't normally go for as a bit more
attractive and appealing and then after
you bust your nut and you've got post
not Clarity like oh what am I doing
there not feeling already exactly that
is true I have a question about about
cheating
who here would like to be able to cheat
in a relationship raise your hand
like to yeah
how many of you would like to be able I
didn't say expect to be able to would
like to be able to cheat in a
relationship like to
explore the ideal situation if she loves
you she's with you but you can cheat
when you want I'd like to we had this
discussion okay exercising options
whatever you would like to have sex with
other girls
yeah no why why not so my younger self
would have said yes but it's like if
you're gonna do that then like I feel
that
hmm how can I how can I word this in a
way that the comments won't kill me
too late nah what I mean is yeah like in
my younger days cheating was easy that
I'll do it and feel no type of way but
now in my older age it's like
I wouldn't necessarily say that's the
right thing and if if you've got
permission to do it then it's different
but if there's no permission and you're
gonna go out and do it then yeah like
it's for me personally gone sorry I
gotta finish no I was gonna say then I
wouldn't want to do it because I'm not
trying to let my woman down like I want
to build up our relationship and I want
us both to be strong enough and we're in
a happy position where we both love and
trust each other would it be a benefit
to you guys if a girl let you cheat like
if she said you know what what you do I
if I don't know about it I don't care
would that be a benefit to you guys of
course I think most men would love that
yeah definitely that's that's your
standard so so how many of you guys that
raised your hand right if your girl put
out whenever you wanted it would you
keep your hand raised I wouldn't look
what do you mean I wouldn't go out of my
way
okay okay because some guys some guys
like they
they variety no matter what so I'm just
like I'm saying if she ever said no
want the right to cheat you know what I
mean
I mean I was still want the right to
cheat but
monogamy is not normal though monogamy's
old has been forced upon men most men if
they had their way and they knew there
would be no pushback from women they
would want to have multiple women yeah I
think it's also because women that
aren't Sometimes women look at sex with
their lenses as opposed to ours our lens
is very much like it's it's a sex is a
physical act yeah it's a physical act
right but most women need to have some
sort of emotional connection even if
they don't the first time the second
time and the third time an emotional
connection will build right so we think
about it differently so therefore it
should be treated differently but they
wanted to us to treat it the same as
them but we're not the same as them so
how can we treat it the same time I'll
just take a tired Playboy like I'm good
I'll take a I'll take a retired player
I'm good you get your fill so a question
how many of you think you could be
faithful to a girl long term like you
have it in you
yeah doing it right now okay so everyone
feels like they could but most of you
would want to cheat if you could and it
would be a benefit if a girl let you do
that it'd make her more wifey I mean if
a girl was to say yo like I want to be
in a relationship with you and I don't
mind if you cheat I don't think any man
is going to be upset about that no man
is probably about it for me but it could
be a test at the same time for me if she
meant it you think it was a you'd think
it was a trap yeah yeah okay yeah for me
the only reason I would half put my hand
up for that is because if she was to say
to me do you know what you can
number one it would make me not even
want to do it anyway but and then number
two the only thing and maybe it's an ego
thing that would exercise is this girl
rates me you know but still I wouldn't
even want to do it but you really have
got love for me because you would really
let me do it nah you're the one but
still
I wouldn't do it and we all know certain
type of men don't cheat so we yes yeah
we wouldn't want to do that I can't like
you know what happens as well actually
in that scenario it will actually make
her more attractive to you so the reason
why I say that is because when you're
dating and you're dating multiple women
and women know that other women want you
they get more excited by them so when it
comes to a situation like that she knows
that he could go and get other guys but
then that being said if you're being
faithful to her and not exercising
options to her she's like I'm the one
who's won but I still the thing is is
competition anxiety in it you need they
need to understand that they should
never think that you can't get anyone
else but them let's let's be wrong
because no woman wants a guy who no
other woman wants it's just not how it
works yeah that's true do I mean like
I'm a faithful man I'll just put it out
there right now faithful man but us get
attention every now and then from girls
and it was my wife up but she knows in
it like obviously I'm not gonna do
anything because I'm a mad man you know
I'm a man of God and that but
it you know it gets them saying okay I
need to be on point I need to be on game
because people are looking at my man
so I mean and that fact is in a to a lot
of positive through your relationship
she's not going to balloon to the size
of a well if she knows that okay this
guy can walk out and he won't even have
to do anything and he can get someone
else she understands what she has so she
stays on her toes yeah that actually as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick-Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible